in the opening scene we see a meteor
that strikes Earth's surface it
disperses numerous extraterrestrial
parasites that are subsequently
nourished by the Flies and other insects
a scene unfolds where a fly lands on a
man and begins sucking his blood during
this process it ejects a microorganism
into his bloodstream that swims deeper
before reproducing more of it the scene
then cuts to the protagonist Malik Khan
a US Marine he wakes up in his secret
facility and watches the news of
escalating riots causing havoc in the
city it appears that the
Extraterrestrial and mind-controlling
alien organisms have invaded the city
and they are infecting the population at
a rapid Pace just then he notices some
bugs entering his room through a small
hole so he immediately kills them with
his spray he also uses repellent spray
on his body to stay away from the bites
Malik's body is tattooed with three
names Jay Bobby and Pia the names of his
sons and his ex-wife Malik hasn't seen
his family for the past 2 years because
he has been out on a secret mission
currently piia and the sons live at a
farmhouse with her new partner Dylan paa
often tries to convince her Elder son
Jay to get along with his stepfather but
the boy doesn't seem to like him PA has
been feeling sick lately probably due to
a mosquito bite but Dylan takes it
lightly thinking that it's just a bug
well so was your father dear and look
what he left me with one night Malik
unexpected drives to his home and wakes
up his two sons he checks their eyes to
see if there is any infection and then
urges them to join him on a supposed
road trip while getting ready Jay
notices a fallen chair in the kitchen a
sign of violence that might have
happened there however he is so excited
to go out with his father that he
ignores it while on the road the kids
ask about the destination but Malik
evades the question labeling it the
surprise just then the police car passes
by and Malik asks his boys to get down
they then then pull over at a gas
station to gather some supplies and
refill their gas while Malik is out Jay
goes through his stuff and sees a case
study and some sketches about the Mind
controlling bugs later on the boy
questions him about it but Malik doesn't
reveal too much hours later they are
pulled over by a patrolling police car
though Malik is polite the officer gets
hostile and aggressive indicating that
he isn't in his correct state of mind
right then Malik sees something moving
behind his eyes and concludes that the
cop has been infected by the parasitic
organism turning him into a pig skito
sensing the imminent danger he opts to
leave but the cop holds him at gunpoint
as a result a physical brawl ensues
between the two fortunately Malik
manages to knock the officer out before
driving away in the aftermath of this
event Malik confesses to his boys that
this is not a road trip but a mission to
rescue Humanity the boys tuck and roll
their asses out of the car because now
they know Daddy's gone insane he reveals
that an Alien Parasite is taken control
over the planet and their mother has
been infected as well he asserts that as
much as half the population has been
infected by this Alien Parasite which is
using human bodies to reproduce Malik
emphasizes their need to get to a secure
facility where scientists are attempting
to find an antidote for the alien
Onslaught in the interim they must
exercise extra caution and Safeguard
themselves from the parasites using bug
spray which acts as a protective barrier
that's lucky the two boys seem to be
scared by this Revelation but they agree
to accompany their dad in the mission
their next stop is a grocery store where
Malik instructs Jay to watch over his
brother while he goes to buy some
supplies during this time an unusual
looking woman approaches the car
frightening the children and prompting
them to run inside the store Malik
manages to calm them down and instructs
them to maintain a low profile to avoid
drawing attention as they continue
continue their Journey on the road the
boys reveal that their mother had been
acting strange lately experiencing
morning sickness and eating weird food
combinations hearing this Malik has a
sudden realization that she might have
been pregnant with a baby or with bugs
he promptly pulls over the car and steps
out to call his parole officer named
Hattie here it is revealed that Malik
has been missing for a while now he
refuses to tell Hattie about his
whereabouts but he asks her to check on
his ex-wife and her partner whom he is
locked up in a garage afterwards Hattie
takes the police to Malik's house and
rescues Pia and Dylan later while
interrogating P informs the authorities
that Malik was doing weird things like
flashing the torch in her eyes and
claiming that she was one of them at
this point it is disclosed that the
aliens aren't real and that Malik has
kidnapped his children we also learn
that Malik had been seeing a
psychiatrist which indicates that he
isn't mentally stable and that he has
been imagined in things about world
destruction that's wild I was just
joking earlier the feds then talked to
Hattie regarding her experience with
Malik in response she tells them that he
is a good and polite guy who loves his
children more than anything and won't
hurt them however the FBI agents don't
believe this because he has a gun with
him furthermore they recount how Malik
had once lost control and brutally
injured his own senior officer leading
him to be imprisoned for 2 years the
agents then decide to track him down as
soon as possible before anything bad
happens later the FBI heads Lance Dunn
and Shephard West conduct a meeting at
headquarters and form a team to locate
Malik they instruct their team to make
all the necessary calls and scan every
pixel of CCTV at every gas station
Shephard believes that Malik has now
manipulated his children and being a
desperate man he can turn on them at any
moment in the same evening Hattie who
wants more insight into the case visits
a bar to meet r a former Marine comrade
of Malik as they Converse Raul describes
the assault incident that caused Malik
to get dishonorably discharged from the
Marine Corps in addition he shows her
some of the letters and dark drawings he
received from Malik all of this makes
her realize that Malik is suffering from
a psychotic disorder due to which he is
having the alien attack hallucinations
on the other hand Malik and his sons are
still on their way to the secure
facility blasting tees Swift and eating
popsicles one night they stop by a huge
field-like area and Camp under a big
rock while Bobby is sleeping Jay and
Malik recount some fun moments from the
past in the midst of their conversation
Malik sees hundreds of meteors in the
sky and Praises their beauty the boy
looks up but finds nothing it is at this
time that Jay begins to suspect that
there is something wrong with his father
early the next morning as the trio is
preparing to resume their Journey they
find that their car's tire is flat
despite this this Malik continues to
drive hoping that they can find a place
to fix it eventually they come across a
car in front of an old cabin Malik
sneaks into the place in search of the
keys but he is suddenly confronted by
the owner because of this the two get
into a physical altercation both of them
go back and forth for a while but in the
end Malik manages to get away after
knocking the man down however he is also
injured in the process following this
Malik teaches Jay how to drive in order
to get them to safety after several
hours of driving they arrive at a
deserted mining town of Los Lunas and
spend the night in an abandoned house
the next morning while Malik sleeps off
his injury Jay drives off to get his
father medicine and food upon arriving
at a store the owner notices Jay's
nervous face and senses something a miss
his suspicion further raises when the
boy hands him a note with some blood
stains he then follows Jay to the car
and offers to help if he is in danger
however the boy pretends to be fine and
drives away on his way back he overhears
on the radio that his father is a wanted
man for kidnapping his two children he
also realizes that his father has misled
them about his 2year secret mission in
reality he was imprisoned in lenworth
for beating up his senior meanwhile the
old man's Sons Dwight and Kurt arrive at
the cabin and find him lying down
unconscious on the floor after calling
an ambulance the two of them set out to
locate the person who attacked their
father when they spot his car on Route
they start pursuing back at the
abandoned house Jay angrily confronts
his father demanding answers with no
options left Malik finally confesses
that he lied about being on a secret
mission he also says that his brain has
been playing tricks on him before they
can discuss further Dwight and Kurt take
Bobby hostage and threaten Malik to
surrender himself when the ladder slowly
opens the door they open fire forcing
him to retreat after instructing Jay to
stay hidden he rushes to the car grabs
his gun and engages in a firefight with
them he eventually manages to save Bobby
and apprehend both men without killing
them after this he steals their car and
escapes with his boys Dad's doing a
pretty good job maybe the aliens are
real yeah it's the rest of the Marines
who are wrong this incident makes Malik
realized that he is a threat to his own
children as a result he stops by a phone
booth and calls Pia he gives her the
address of a diner saying that he will
be leaving the kids there Pia tries to
persuade him to surrender but he refuses
to go back to prison he then bids a
final goodbye to his children and
continues his road trip he's heading to
Disney World to fulfill his lifelong
dream of meeting Donald Duck a while
later the FBI agents along with Hattie
arrive at the diner but they only find
Bobby it turns out that Jay is still in
Malik's car hiding in the back seat
seeing him Malik shouts at him
emphasizing that he is supposed to be
with Bobby you're ruining my plans to
see Donald however Jay responds that
Bobby is not the one who needs him now
the FBI agents and the police are behind
them chasing in their cars and
helicopters after a long and intense
chase the authorities surround them and
hold the car at gunpoint Shephard walks
out and calls Malik politely asking him
to surrender he also lets him talk to
Hattie who is the only person he trusts
she insists to Malik that the
authorities will take his mental health
into consideration when deciding his
fate she also urges him to send the boy
out of the car but Jay refuses to to
abandon his father even after an
hour-long standoff with the police Malik
then apologizes to Jay for being an
irresponsible father who endangered his
children he breaks down in tears but the
boy consoles him by saying that he is
still his hero amidst their emotional
conversation Malik notices the FBI
trying to sneak up to him so he loses
his temper and opens fire in the air
thankfully Jay manages to calm him down
and takes the gun from his hand not
wanting to lose his father Jay runs out
of the car and points a gun at the
police fearing that his boy might get
shot Malik hastily jumps out of the car
and tries to divert the Authority's
attention towards himself as the intense
situation escalates Malik somehow
manages to convince Jay to drop the gun
and run to them the movie ends as the
father and son Embrace with the police
lowering their weapons subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching